well as I was saying thanks for coming
and before I introduce Galen and Tom I
want to thank rich and Barbara Frankie
who are the generous donors that make
these Frankie lectures and seminars
possible as you probably know if you've
been to any of these before this is part
of the secret life of radio it's a
Frankie lecture and seminar we have a
seminar that's going on the students are
here and in addition we got these
evening lectures and this is the fourth
in our series on the secret life of
radio I'm delighted to introduce
challenges of Hunter and Tom Rowe to you
or the dynamic team behind wave farm
wave farm is a non-profit arts
organization that's dedication
dedicated to experimentation with
broadcast media and the airwaves located
on a large 29 acre property in in
upstate New York wave farm is many many
things
it is a terrestrial radio station
broadcasting on wgx sea 90.7 FM with
access to the Hudson Valley communities
it's a research center for work in the
transmission arts with an extensive
library and archive it's a site for
artistic residency's and for artists
working with the radio spectrum it's a
place of site-specific transmission arts
many of which are streaming 24/7 on the
Internet including a hydrophone
broadcasting from a pond on the property
and the wonderful weather warlock it
weather controlled analog synthesizer
which is perfect if John Durham Peters
were here this is your thing your Jam
their visionary work has really helped
to demonstrate a model of what
terrestrial radio in the United States
can be namely community-based focus on
access to the airwaves encouraging
creative exploration of the radio
spectrum and cultivating new radio works
and programming Galen is the executive
director with an extension background in
nonprofit arts administration in arts
curation for writings on the
transmission arts namely as the author
of the book transmission arts artisan
Airways from 2011 and as editor and
author of the special issue of paj
Journal of performance and art on the
transmission arts have you even precise
conceptual articulation to the notion of
the transmission arts and they've helped
to direct attention to the history and
contemporary vibrancy of the stunning
variety of artistic work that's being
done with the radio frequency spectrum
tommrow is the artistic director he's
the sound transmission artist he's self
radio host and one of the original
founders of
three 103.9 pirate radio station in in
Brooklyn which eventually transformed
into wave farm starting as a so-called
radio pirate and traversing the worlds
of micro casting low powered FM and now
wave farm Tom's artistic work and his
knowledge has been crucial to developing
to the developing community of
transmission artists who intersected
with three 103.9 and now with wave farm
and enlarge development of the
transmission arts more generally he's
acted as a performer a writer a lecturer
and educator on the history of radio
performance and micro casting Galen and
Tom are true and tireless pioneers in
the transmission arts very grateful to
have them here today and when I first
thought of this series of the secret
life of radio I really couldn't imagine
doing it without inviting Galen and Tom
to come speak so without further ado
gala just honor and Tom thank you for
being good thanks everybody it's
pleasure to be here we had a great time
with the seminar students earlier today
and it's terrific to be able to delve a
bit deeper into some of the projects
Brian mentioned and so much we just
started to allude to earlier so what
you're looking at is the this resolution
is not super but uh so my apologies but
um you're looking at the home screen of
wave farm org and and which currently
features a photograph of Zach puff spawn
station and we'll talk about that in
just a bit but first a little background
in context about wave farm our mission
statement is up there it says we are a
nonprofit arts organization driven by
experimentation with broadcast media and
the airwaves a pioneer of the
transmission arts genre wave farm
programs provide access to transmission
technologies and support artists and
organizations that engage with media as
an art form
we began in March 1997 as a micro
casting collective micro casting was
kind of the word used by the pirate
radio community to
to distinguish ourselves from
broadcasting broadcasting is casting to
a large area micro casting is casting to
a small area that's simple but there
were thousands of pirate radio stations
across the country at this time a
loosely banded together to try to effect
change and eventually we got that change
over the course of two laws got passed
through Congress and there are now 3,000
or 4,000 legal low-power FM stations
across the country providing people with
community access so we started that way
in Brooklyn 97 we until 2004 we had a
space in Brooklyn right next to the
Williamsburg Bridge where we hosted
experimental performances radio
experiments and more and then we became
a nonprofit arts group around 2004 to
that 2003 we're married so we're gonna
correct each other who is this talk goes
on that airwaves are public space and
should therefore be accessible by the
public and that airwaves should be
available for creative purposes
experimentation and risk-taking is the
ideology that has driven our activities
since its inception as Tom mentioned we
became nonprofit in 2003 we involved
from an artist collective to an arts
organization whose mission is to define
and cultivate transmission arts in 2005
we expanded activities up to Green
County in upstate New York launching an
artist residency program outdoor
performance series and installation park
on a 29 acre property called wave farm
in 2007 we found out I guess the Federal
Communications Commission is about every
20 years or so kind of inventories its
airwaves and said oh we've got a number
of airwaves that could be open
frequencies that could be used and so
they had this full power open
application process for nonprofit groups
in 2007 to apply for full power stations
and we did and we won out in our area
against
national church organizations that file
thousands of applications all at once
through their computers but we had more
local points and so we got WG xc90 point
seven of 3,300 watt station that covers
a good swath of the Hudson Valley right
and the station was designed to serve
both sides of the organization's roots
radio art and activism on the airwaves
so some may recognize sex and
broadcasting as the title of the 2014
documentary about WF mu but the titles
origin is from this book sex in
broadcasting a handbook on starting
community radio stations written by
Lorenzo Milan in the early 70s this is a
copy of the volume in the way from study
centre library it's the 1972 edition and
Tom's gonna share just a brief passage
from this lively publication Oh radio
broadcasting as it exists as it exists
now in the United States it's a pitiful
unmitigated horror at some state in its
history there was a chance to turn it to
a creative artful caring medium but then
all the toads came along realizing the
power of radio and television to hop
they're awful where's the saga of
broadcasting in America is littered with
the bodies of those who wanted to do
something significant and who were
driven out or more correctly sold out by
the pimps and thieves who now run the
media so today nearly 50 years later so
much but so very little has changed in
his book Elma long offers and extremely
entertaining while remarkably
informative guide to starting a
community radio station and this is you
know something as tom was saying before
that we at wave farm have a first-hand
knowledge of and will we'll talk more
about later but I mentioned Elm Alam
here because the sentiments in the
passage Thom performed resonate deeply
with wave farms mission at large so
that's our dog - and we do all kinds of
radio at wave and on the left is a
diagram attempting to outline the
expansive activities
away from radio so they include gxc is
mentioned and do you know anything else
about GXE at this moment you mentioned
the listenership already right I did the
wattage did you say the wattage I didn't
say the listenership was potentially
78,000 plus but I think the dog image is
up because we try to give access to the
airwaves to everyone all kinds of people
from eight-year-olds to 80 year olds are
on the station but also there are local
owls and fish and dogs on the station
too
this is true and under continuous
streams you'll see mention of several
the long term site-specific
installations on the property which Tom
hinted at trans transmit partners is a
rapidly expanding network of like
like-minded organizations and
individuals they're using the way from
radio app and our streaming server to
share their own content and listeners
can tune in via the partners website the
app our website and then we often pick
up these streams and relay them out to
via fm to the listeners of wgx like
1930s radio where you would hear an
orchestra on the air
eight o'clock live from some venue in
Chicago or New York City on our radio
station you'll hear band performing at
the Avalon lounge at Catskill or
Basilica Hudson or s la inspires in
Brattleboro or something so that's just
a snapshot of the partners so and the
partners really enable a place where
community radio community media and the
transmission aren't transmission arts
converged so we keep saying transmission
art what do we mean by transmission art
we say artists experiment eight
experiments with the electromagnetic
spectrum a sub-genre of the media arts
we define transmission art as
encompassing works where the
electromagnetic spectrum is an
intentional actor either formerly or
conceptually the electromagnetic
spectrum is vast includes seven primary
types of waves radio
waves microwaves infrared rays waves
visible light rays ultraviolet waves
x-rays and gamma rays and you guys
thought I was going to sing the song but
I didn't I could maybe later
naturally-occurring radio and
astronomical objects radio related
projects either conventional radio art
works audio made explicitly for radio
broadcast or do-it-yourself radio based
installation and performance where
artists might build their own
transmission and receiving devices or
common manifestations of transmission
art in action another common trajectory
of the genre is making the ethereal
tangible for example works that
demonstrate a physical delineation of
space through sonic or visual
representation the architecture of
transmission and reception transmission
art encompasses works where the act of
transmitting or receiving is not only
significant but the fulcrum for the
artists intention these works often
challenged conventional relationships of
transmitter or artist and receiver or
audience and they celebrate a Brecht
opion utopia interactive the Brecht took
the Breck's utopia vision for two-way
interactive media when we talk about
radio out of bounds we mean artists who
approach the medium of radio
unconventionally radio waves are the
medium and the subject literally
conceptually even spectively so here
you're looking at the United States
frequency allocation of the radio
spectrum and color is revealed on the
parts of the spectrum utilized by the
artists and projects we'll talk about
and listen to in just a moment and at
the bottom you see where radio sits
within the larger electromagnetic
spectrum and because wave farm and the
community of artists we work with are
tend to fetishize these sorts of
illustrations I'll share with you max
Goldfarb Maximilian Goldfarb's 2017
limited edition print which he created
on the occasion of wave farms 20th
anniversary so Goldfarb's drawing
interprets and illustrates the radio
frequency allocation chart at the bottom
you can recognize it there as well as
transceiver and wireless router circuit
at the top so this is an edition of 200
and the dimensions for reference are
roughly like 21 inches by 24 this is
wave farm in ecru New York the waveform
study Center is what the we call the
building
it has a research library and listening
library there are two bedrooms for
mostly for our artists and residency
program although we also have visiting
artists often come there's a I guess two
radio studios in the building and am I
missing anything else workspaces offices
120 to mention the library I did mention
the libraries on 29 acres and we do all
kinds of live broadcast there's also a
radio truck we'll show you on the
property where we can broadcast from and
some other things out in the fields
alright so let's explore a few artists
and artworks that embody radio
out-of-bounds
the first is Erin dill ways everyone
eats garbage created during his 2018
residency at wave firm dill away is a
celebrated improviser and composer who
works with quarter-inch tape loops in
8-track cartridges as well as other
discarded electronic equipment you get a
sense of his kind of work space on the
right there
in his performance based practice he
manipulates magnetic tape in a real-time
by feeding the loops sounds from his own
body everyday objects electronic sources
prepared tapes as well as the occasional
actual musical instrument everyone eats
garbage is an example of an artist
drawing from the literal physical tools
of radio to create something for
conventional broadcasts presentation
it's radio folded back onto itself radio
on the radio he's using these tape carts
this radio cart machines are basically
like cassette players or 8-track players
made just for radio off the tape is
usually just like a minute long or 30
seconds long and it just holds one
advertised
or one station ID or one or one sound
effective dish noise or a jackhammer or
a typewriter as we see here
so everyone eats garbage is a radio work
informed by a large archive of obsolete
sound effect tape carts that were once
used by kxl you 88.9 FM in Los Angeles
and Delaware extends the life of these
abandoned and outdated radio artifacts
by cutting slicing looping and
manipulating them into new and
substantial work for broadcast and we
will take a listen to maybe two minutes
of it now that's Aaron whoops yes
[Music]
[Music]
so--that's was more of like a
minute-and-a-half because I think we're
running long but uh the whole piece is
just over 30 minutes and available on
the way from website if anyone's
interested in listening in totality so
let's jump back in time to the
influential artist Jose meseta who was
born in Manila in 1917 and died in 2004
he was incredibly prolific it remains
under recognized by most contemporary
scholars the artist Aki onda has been
researching and speaking about Mussina's
work with frequency and is restaging his
eyen 420 radio stations at the Friedman
gallery in New York as part of the New
Year Festival this January in a talk
earlier this year at the Asia art
archive onda describes boobie nyan for
20 radios as one of Miss ITA's
masterpieces and probably the most
ambitious provocative and controversial
works among his repertoire
it's a 51 minute long piece that
consists of 20 recorded tracks Agnon
explores the same concept that meseta
used for an earlier work called cassette
100 which was performed at the cultural
center of the philippines in 71
where a hundred participants carried
cassette players up and down the center
staircases their movements were
choreographed with intention so the
sounds would move and fly inside the
space nyan engages a similar idea
multi-tracks multi sounds impacted by
the environment and the participants but
this time meseta used actual radio
stations as the transmission spectrum
for sound diffusion with the assistance
of Imelda Marcos who was the president
of the Philippines cultural center
during 100 cassettes Macedo is able to
employ all 37 radio stations in
metropolitan Manila and let's just take
a moment to really appreciate that no
other radio programming hurt was heard
during the event all of the stations in
Manila were participating playing one of
the 20 tracks of denying it was
broadcast on New Year's Day and
in 74 from 6:00 to 7:00 p.m. they
identified 142 listening sites across
Manila where audiences were encouraged
to bring a transistor radio and catch
one of the radio frequencies and they
say between 2 and 20 million people were
listening to that broadcast the scale of
the project was unprecedented it was
possibly the biggest event in the field
of avant-garde Arts in Asia at that time
so uh Keown does restaging of agnya at
friedman will be realized in
collaboration with wave farm and we're
recreating it as a microcast
installation it's a gallery specific
version that's going to use 20 different
low-power FM transmitters each operating
on a unique frequency and then there'll
be radio receivers position throughout
the gallery space so obviously being
inside of an environment with 20
different frequencies being active and
alive is a very different experience
than what I'm going to play for you now
but in 2010 John Zorn Zadok label put
out a stereo recording of the piece so
we can just give you a little sense of
what it sounds like
and this is what it sounded like on one
frequency I think this is a they say
it's a stereo recording but it'll be
much more spatial and multi-channel in
the gallery all right so about 40 years
later and bears radio organ is another
artists approach to occupying the FM
spectrum this experimental array of
micro radio transmitters is a
multi-channel synthesizer transmitting
to any and every available station
across the FM spectrum to create the
organ bearer prepared or hacked early
devices called I trips which were
intended to connect iPods to car radios
and like Mussina's work bears organ and
bodies dynamic in both scale and content
physical space where every station on
your FM dial is composed and hopefully
the volume is gonna be okay here let's
see
this is Edie talking about the piece in
2015
the ideas to mine I work a lot with
found electronics reused electronics or
you a citizen or things that are gonna
become a waste each one of these used to
be an eye trip which was meant to
transmit from your iPod to your car
radio but this is intensely obsolete and
you can buy these for 10 cents apiece on
emails by and the OMA they look like
this and they're really just the radio
transmitter once you you knock them a
little bit what's neat about this is
that I created this little parasitic
circuit that plugs into the connector
and I trip that when you wire them all
together lets them talk to one another
let's talk to a computer us and talk to
or many senses of is kind of its
mechanism inside of each one of these
transmitters and that it's a little
computer that can be used to do you know
anything that you can tell a computer to
do that then you can hook that a
computer up to those that then if you
look that computer up to that side it's
a little set a little modular
synthesizer which you can plug other
sound sources into that will end up on
the radio or it can synthesize its own
sounds and it's a different radio
stations that is be programmatically
control what station their trains
[Music]
200 seconds to radius here I'll turn to
one to one state
change the station
here now this radio station is picking
out the silence that this is
[Music]
[Music]
all right
hmm so Jeff Thompson's every radio
station developed while in residence
also makes use of the entire fom
spectrum in a given location Thompson
says while we only hear one radio
station at a time typically the
terrestrial radio spectrum is an
artificially divided continuum filling
the air around us this is this
installation makes the FM spectrum
physical 95 handle FM radios one for
each slot in the FM band form a 30-foot
line all of the radios play
simultaneously letting visitors hear the
entire spectrum at once or walk closely
along the line to hear the station's
individually for each location the piece
is installed in a totally different
sonic experience occurrs obviously based
on what's happening in terms of the
radio spectrum in that location and
Thompson predicts that as reallocation
of the radio spectrum happened moves to
streaming devices that the piece 2 will
reflect those changes the piece isn't as
cacophonous as you might expect this is
installed at the Friedman gallery it was
also reinstalled at the school of the
Museum of Fine Arts in Boston it's kind
of a white noise kind of enjoyable low
hum fuzz and then as you walk along it
you hear each individual station make
have a little sample recording here
[Music]
[Music]
they get the idea so moving away from
the FM spectrum montreal-based artists
gamble tron used her residency to
further develop drone oscillator a
large-scale multi tonal and radio
Thurman and theremin if you don't know
is a instrument that uses
electromagnetic frequencies that you
don't touch to make sound by changing
the frequency or and/or the pitch and so
you want to play a little bit of that
yeah let's see
so her residency culminated culminated
with an installation and performance on
the Elana historic site state site
location in a event called groundswell
that way farm organized annually over
three years and this is gamble Tron
outfitted as the third radio in her
theremin and she's going to tell us a
little bit about it
spot makes two-way farm in this
residency I really note that that occurs
in and the Thurman Rose it is constantly
moving the dog goes down so that the
court changes it changes with wind
changes with the presence of people that
changes for whatever reason I find it so
much easier you just explain it as magic
[Music]
so yeah you get the two radios we tune
them in the am frequency usually in the
higher end and you look for the dead
zone and then you'd get a third radio
and he put it in front and you start
tuning that it was one point that you
have to find we touch the antennas of
that one point of them back you don't
have to solder you can even alligator
clips it's bang it's a theremin
literally like there's an antenna and
you go close and far the note changes
like he read so my arm is the antenna in
this demonstration
[Music]
all right so moving slightly farther out
of the bounds of radio Zack Poth who he
saw this image earlier engages a
different sort of site-specific
environment with his pond station pond
station transmits the hidden activity
within a pond at wave farm from dawn
until sundown
it's a solar-powered structure floats
atop the springfed pond and suspended
from it are a pair of custom built by
paw hydrophones revealing what is
typically unheard sounds from within the
pond and then the sound is transmitted
is broadcast to local listeners on an AM
station we have specific to the property
as well as the fmw GXE and online to
international audiences so pond station
like many of the works at Wave farms is
functions as a standalone work of art
but also an interactive instrument for
visiting artists we've had people play
the Japanese flute and duet with pond
station or float sonic objects and then
record the stream or spoken word shout
it into the pond because water sound
waves travels through water a long
distance and great so you can yell into
the side of the pond and the waves will
go into through the water into the
microphone which is on the picture on
the right the microphone on the bottom
is on the bottom protected by that metal
to stop the beaver from chewing on it
which did actually happen nice we were
talking about before yes the beavers
chewed on the microphone and the turtles
love to live on top of the styrofoam on
this floating part they like to send
themselves there so you get those sounds
and all kinds of other sounds and this
is just a minute of pond station look
that's still gamble Chand talking and
this is from a reigning afternoon
recording let's see
it's pretty meditative another project
that's responsive to weather is Quintron
sweater warlock and this has sensors
outside on the left here that sense the
changes in precipitation where it says
snow the changes in sunlight changes in
wind and the changes in temperature and
then it converts those changes into
sound and then all the other knobs let
artists manipulate the weather or the
sounds of the change in the weather
however they want in this project
streams also on the website 24/7 oh
actually 23 seven because we shut it
down for one hour every night because
Quintron says that his electronics need
to take a nap and the pond is
solar-powered so it only broadcast when
there's daylight and then it lasts like
an hour after sunset so here's a little
bit of what the weather warlock sounds
like
and so it sounds radically different if
there's a lot of change in the weather
and it sounds you know more boring when
there's no change in the weather and if
you're listening to online stream you
know as a listener you don't really know
if someone's in the studio playing the
instrument or not and we do our local
morning weather forecast with this
playing in the sound of the pond playing
in an outside mic playing so you don't
even hear just the forecast you hear the
sound of the actual weather at the
moment all right
test sight of the acoustic Commons was
installed by london-based grant Smith of
sound camp at the conclusion of a wave
farm residency just last month it's a
listening point linked to an online
network of open microphones it's a
stream box on the edge of a woodland at
Wave farm and it sends a live feed to
the server at locust sonís in Marseille
France where it is publicly accessible
on a real-time sound map by placing such
sites in the public domain
tsa see for short makes local sounds
available to listeners for whatever
purposes this can be a way to pay
attention to under recognized places to
study their changing sound scapes
through days seasons and long durations
and a tune between local and planetary
scales
so there's omnidirectional microphones
which are open to the full range of
sounds reaching the stream box this can
include insects wind in different
seasons of foliage Birds Plains pasture
bys flows of traffic on the nearby route
23 but the best noises are the owls the
coyotes and the frogs this is the locust
sonís sound map so these are all open
microphones on the left here and then if
you zoom in to the wave farm location
you see the two microphones one being
pond station which also uses locust
sonís and the other the test site of
acoustic Commons
and let's see if we can listen live
locust onus is like wave farm is a
archival place or for transmission or
locus onus is the portal for field
recordings from around the world it's
taking a second to connect let's see if
it's gonna connect doesn't look like it
well maybe not
I wonder well anyway it's on that it's
on the waveform website and if we were
listening live it would basically be the
sounds of what's happening literally at
wave from right now probably some
occasional traffic maybe some bees red
or later tonight when the snowstorm
starts yeah um so the most recent
installation wave farm is now nearly
complete its pictured on the left here
it's called here goes radio telescope
phase one of the project is purely
visual in keeping with the other
projects on the property it aims to
activate and reveal otherwise unnoticed
or inaccessible aspects of the
environment that utilize the
electromagnetic spectrum
here goes creates an avenue for
individuals to directly relate to the
usually invisible infrastructure we rely
on the diagram displayed on the right
demystifies a bit of what's happening
inside the wooden clad reclining
structure a visitor climbs into the
structure and views an inset monitor
that displays the image stream from the
goes sixteen weather satellites constant
radio transmission goes sixteen is a
geostationary satellite operated by NOAA
and used to track weather activity the
stream serves as a reminder of the
ubiquitous and visible radio data
surrounding us and how much we rely on
our orbiting infrastructure and these
streams for weather forecasting storm
monitoring because in height and many
other services by receiving the status
stream as individuals we participate
directly in these activities and are
reminded that such unmediated
participation is possible this is a
sample of what the images look like they
the
project collects about a terabyte of
information daily is there like
extremely high-resolution images that
are not available anywhere on the
Internet they're used by AccuWeather and
NASA and organizations like this to help
predict weather patterns and you have to
actually sit there and wait for the
three seconds for the signal to come
down from the satellite so you get a
sense of actually how waves work and
travel so it's like just under three
seconds for 22,000 miles travel this is
a close-up of that seeing a detail of
the image you just saw before trying to
convey a little bit of resolution and
we're trying to fight with it now
because I guess Halloween night there
was a big storm charlie it's big storm
down here - it was a big storm up where
we are and it blew the satellite
receiver maybe a half a millimeter to
one side and a half a millimeter is when
you're shooting at a satellite in space
it's like you're miles and miles and
miles off now so we're trying to get it
back there are some guy wires in our
future so we will uh finish up with
something unfinished this is Rex
unfinished typescript from 1927
published in the Bloomsbury brecht on
film and radio on utilizations the
question of how art can be utilized for
the radio and how the radio can be
utilized for art two very different
questions must at some point be
subordinated to the much more important
question of how art and the radio can be
utilized at all if we are right or
judged to be in the right then this
question will be answered in the
following way art and the radio must be
put to pedagogical purposes the
possibility of implementing such a
direct pedagogical utilization of art
does not seem feasible today because the
state has no interest in educating its
youth about collectivism art must
intervene where the defect is to be
found if seeing is not involved it does
not mean that one sees nothing but
equally that one sees in an infinity of
things whatever you like and thank you
guys so much for having us
we're doing Q&A if there are any
stepping back you're not participating
alone
how should we do it yeah personal
favorites the I'm the pond station of
weather warlock are probably my
favorites because the pond station just
sounds so different than maybe what you
expect underwater to sound like and I've
been a huge fan of Quint Ron's work for
20 years or so so getting to work with
him was exciting yeah I'd agree on
whether warlock I didn't know I do a lot
of grant writing or wave farm and I tend
to listen to whether warlock in the
background I find it very as a soothing
therapeutic soundtrack and then the here
goes radio telescope which is like just
such an incredible feat that Heidi
Nielsen and Harry Deb Robinson have
pulled off it's their estimate they know
of five other civilian listening
stations around the world but they're
like with no budget they've they're
listening to this they actually say I
got a big satellite it's like a
satellite TV dish it's a ten foot dish
that heíd used in a prior project and
then they used it wasn't quite getting
the signal so they put as a guinea pig
wire yeah
so it's basically the last foot of the
satellite is guinea pig wire that they
attach themselves to make it a larger
receiver and a better receiver for very
little money worked
yes swimming correctly you know what the
most the most obvious is that the
palette changed working with radio in
Brooklyn was there's not much static
there's every single space on the dial
is full of either a pirate or a
commercial legal signal up where we are
there are spaces where there aren't a
radio station on every single spate
there certainly are any other pirates
that we know of are here so yeah we
talked about moving upstate to have more
space both on the radio dial in physical
space for artists who are working in
this way and then the the FM radio
station we didn't know that was gonna be
a possibility when we moved up but as
soon as that entered the picture then we
were like it's basically like put your
money where your mouth is you're talking
about radio as parkland and that people
should be able to have access to their
own airwaves
so wgx II was born we gave many many
talks about radio as parkland and radio
as should be owned by the public and
accessible to the public so when the the
license was available we went for it
right away but but - I guess to your
point some were before we were lit up
beaming - probably more like-minded
people in Brooklyn and now we're beaming
- a lot of people who have probably
never considered the concept of art on
the radio or radio as art we're
certainly a broadcast into a
conservative base that went to - one for
Trump and so it's a much different thing
and we're and we're also bringing local
community voices and high schoolers
running a candidate forum to an
international radio art listenership
who's listening to the stream online so
it's like a and introducing we found
we've trained community programs to do
community radio shows but they are
picking up what's going on on the rest
of the station with the radio art and I
incorporating that into their shows too
so it's a weird it's a weird hybrid a
wonderful hybrid you had it's all
available it's we mostly use Creative
Commons rules so they're they're up
there with Creative Commons rules Thanks
are you are you pointing to people with
questions I just was cuz that person was
me why don't you go ahead back so the
marseille is where locus onus is right
which is the where the server locus onus
is the name of the web site and the art
that that is sort of a portal for field
recordings right it's associated with
the university but locus loc u.s. sonís
sound camp is the project of the
london-based artist grant Smith who
works a lot with locust sonís the he's
doing these creating these new stream
boxes that are called acoustic Commons
and the first one he was installing it
wave farm this October but sound camp
one project that they do that we've
worked with them on for since its
inception six years ago
it's called reveille and it's the first
Saturday of May it's timed with the
international dawn chorus day and it is
the sound of daybreak starting in London
and traveling around the globe and so we
do that as a 4:25 broadcast it moves
from London at 6 a.m. to
Ireland at 6:00 a.m. to Iceland at 6:00
a.m. to Greenland at 6:00 a.m. to Nova
Scotia at 6:00 a.m. to New York at 6
a.m. and sometimes it picks up
underwater sounds in the ocean the
microphones there sometimes it picks up
air traffic control sounds if there's
it's somewhere over the Pacific Ocean
where there's not an open mic but mostly
it's birds because birds start singing
at the beginning of each day and it's
just sort of beautiful but the locusts
own a snap each one of those little
microphone icons is an open mic that you
can listen to and mix if you so choose
any day of the year yeah yes yes
so the clips we played um we're kind of
noisy and not all that that's not what
all radio art is necessarily but I do
you played some Gregory Whitehead for
some people that's radically different
yes non noisy and kind of a with its
speech and voice but I think you could
apply the same like aesthetic choice and
reaction to any medium or art form so
it's basically what is provocative to
you in what is enjoyable or unenjoyable
enough that it makes you think and react
we're probably more on the experimental
and avant
and more traditional radio art is
probably is often more vocal based and
more recognizable probably like then it
starts to toe the line with people who
identify as independent radio producers
and then you start to get into kind of
like podcast world which we're sort of
antithetical to yeah
she'd been part of an orchestra she is a
musician also so I don't know if she's
used not sure if she has but that's a
very interesting question she may have
she probably had the residency program
people apply you know we have several
hundred applications every year we have
to go through them but they apply with a
specific project that's usually their
own project or something with a
collaborator does that start the
question answer yeah but in terms of
like whether that proposal is we want to
install an open microphone on the way
from property and it will become one of
your installations or if it's I'm gonna
come and work on this this sound work
about my Iranian uncle who was a radio
producer that was imprisoned like that
was another example of a resident this
year and Malad mazar-e is that artists
name and he was a joy to have around but
when he left his project went with him
so it's it's I don't know statistically
several artists have come to us with big
projects that have lots of different
parts and they come to work on just the
radio part with us and so there are many
different ways that work anytime
someone's a resident with us they have
an open-door invitation to return as
long as there's room at the end so it's
you know there's a kind of a building of
community that happens that way
anybody else no all right thank you
everybody
[Music]